A
I CAN'T.
>> Sandra: THANKS, NATE.
WHERE IS ALL OF THIS HEAD
SOMETHING LOOKS ASK FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER TO
MIKE PENCE, GENERAL KEITH
KELLOGG.
THANKS, GENERAL.
YOU'VE JOINED US FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
WHERE DOES THIS GO NEXT, SIR?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
WE'RE THERE TO THE WINTER AFTER
300 DAYS.
THE RUSSIANS ARE REGROUPING.
THEY'RE RE-MANNING WITH
MOBILIZATION.
WINTER IS HARD ON EVERYBODY.
THE COMMENT MADE ABOUT KISSINGER
IS TRUE.
WHAT KISSINGER SAY IS HE WANTS
TO GO BACK TO THE STATUS QUO.
THAT MEANS OKAY, THE RUSSIANS
LEAVE THE AREAS BUT THEY'LL KEEP
CRIMEA.
WE SHOULDN'T BUY INTO THAT.
IF I WAS RECOMMENDING SOMETHING
TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, I'D SAY WE NEED TO GO
ALL IN.
WE NEED TO PUT PRESSURE ON
PUTIN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO PICK UP
THE PHONE AND CALL PUTIN AND SAY
LOOK, WE'RE GOING ALL IN WITH
EVERYTHING WE'VE GOT.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS WE WANT
THE RUSSIAN ARMY IN THE FIELD IN
UKRAINE TO BE DEFEATED.
THAT MEANS PUTIN FALLS.
THIS GOES BACK TO WHAT HAPPENED
WITH STAR NICHOLAS AT THE END OF
WORLD WAR I WHEN THE RUSSIAN
ARMY MUTINYED AND HE LEFT.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
RIGHT NOW ZELENSKY IS NOT IN THE
MOOD TO M
NEGOTIATE.
HE SAID THAT HE'S GOING AFTER
CRIMEA AS WELL.
WE SHOULDN'T LET UP ON ANY OF
THE EQUIPPING THAT WE'VE GONE TO
THE UKRAINIANS.
WE NEED TO WATCH IT AND KNOW
WHERE IT'S GOING AND WE NEED TO
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY BUT WE
SHOULDN'T BACK UP.
WE HAVE LEVERAGE WITH ZELENSKY.
WE PROVIDED 75% OF THE
EQUIPMENT, THE HUMANITARIAN AID
AND ECONOMIC AID.
THAT'S THE SAME LEVERAGE ON A
PUTIN.
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID, AS
LONG AS IT TAKES, WHATEVER IT
TAKES, THAT A BUMPER STICKER.
IT'S NOT A POLICY.
HENESS A POLICY AND END STATE
AND NEEDS TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHAT THAT END STATE IS.